So Michael, you make some of the most amazing swords we've ever seen.
It's an epic thing.
How'd you get involved in this?
Well, I was born in the 80s, so there was lots of fantasy movies when I was young and...
...it was very hard in Ireland to buy a sword.
I'm lucky that way that there was no Amazon.com or there was no...
...I mean, I came from a small town so if I wanted a sword,...
...the only way to make it was, the only way to get it was to make it.
I have become the giant sword guy because you can't get them anywhere else.
I'm the guy on planet Earth you have to come to if you want a big, giant sword.
Who's your average customer and what are they looking for?
They all like video games.
They're looking for a giant sword but they can't buy it...
...because they're too big to be mass-produced by China.
And these are video game swords or weapons...
...that people see and play these video games with...
...and then they say, "I want the real thing."
Yeah!
So usually it's weird ones and the Buster Sword is too big,...
...that's the mean one I make.
That was 54 pounds.
A historical sword whose been between three and five pounds.
I got a bodybuilder here on the island to try and use this in the video,...
...and I thought he'd be better at using it than me.
But it turns out that at that weight and size, that the human body,...
...54 pounds' worth of metal doesn't care how long you've been at the gym.